If we're being real, if you want to have
a real conversation, it looks like Tate
regrets becoming Muslim.
>> Andrew Tate, do you believe you're going
to find happiness knowing that you are
the cause of destruction of thousands of
families who are gambling, who are on
the verge of suicide? Yes. Do you think
you're ever going to find happiness when
the curse of those people are on you? On
you. Shame on you as a Muslim. You are
promoting gambling and you've got your
own gambling website. Shame on you. And
we are going to call you out because you
are fake. That's what you don't give a
crap about anyone.
Once you're in that grave, there's no I
could have, I would have, I should have.
Case closed. Allah tells us that a man
when he is sold is taken away. Allah
says he's going to say what? Send me
back to do Hajj, Omrah, salah, fasting,
what? No sodak. Brothers and sisters,
aya is getting thousands of shahadas
monthly, yearly. Hundreds of thousands
of people are coming to Islam. They are
printing Quran, distributing material,
training duat. Brothers and sisters, do
you want the part of that goes on
forever? This is how Islam has spread
around the world brother and sisters
carry on this legacy of the prophetam
inshallah by donating whatever amount
inshallah and support ayra right now
inshallah enjoy the video
brothers and sisters and dear friends
here's another video subhan allah coming
to you guys showing and I think it's
it's our duty the reason I'm talking
about I will not stop talking is because
when he first came to Islam we defended
him pro I want to say promoted him but
spoke about the good that he does
defended him about the accusations etc
and now it is time that we have to warn
against this And that's why guys always
say it's nothing personal with me. When
I advise sisters or brothers or whoever
they are for that matter, it's nothing
personal. It's genuinely for the sake of
Allah subhana wa tala. Yes. If you're
going to come out there and cause harm
to the people, I'm going to speak out
against it. I don't give a damn if you
come to my family or like as you guys
know like recent pictures released of me
and my wife and my kids. Alhamdulillah.
Which made me look even fantastic. And
please for the second wife proposals.
No. Yes. Okay. Um I understand you know
I looked good the father of the year or
the husband of the year but please no
thank you very much. Um, so you can see,
and I'm being generally honest, guys,
you can come for my mom, my dad, my my
my kids pictures, my granddad's
pictures, my mom's pictures, my wife
pictures, uh, you name it. You know, if
I had four wives, bring all the four
wives pictures. I'll never stop
speaking. Alhamdulillah. Just want to
make that very clear. So with Andrew
Tate, it's the same thing. I don't care.
Now guys, we're going to watch in we're
going to watch brother uh we're going to
watch brother Sony, someone that I met
in Omra. Alhamdulillah, beautiful
brother and Sneo. At least they're
consistent. wall. When I look at these
people, you can see the iman, you can
see the you can see the trust in Allah,
you can seehed. Here's what 25 had to
say. And I have to applaud the guy. I
have to applaud the guy. Wall genuinely
I I I I look up to him. I look up to
him.
>> There's no way Tate's promoting
gambling. What? There's no way Tate's
promoting gambling. What?
This is real.
Yo, Tate, bro, you had the potential to
go to the highest ranks of heaven,
literally chilling with the prophets.
You have that potential with how many
people you've brought closer to God and
how many people you've woken up and
gotten in touch with their masculinity.
And now you're promoting gambling, bro.
Why? You have millions of dollars, man.
[snorts]
Why would you need to promote gambling?
What's wrong with you, dude? I can't
believe I used to look up to this guy,
bro. What's wrong with him?
>> You see this?
>> What?
>> We got to cover this, bro. What's going
on with Tate? I'm sick of
>> I'm sick of Dude, defending him, bro.
>> Imagine you're the only reason he gets
into cuz you,
>> bro.
>> Imagine you're the reason
>> I didn't convert because of Tate,
though, so [clears throat] has nothing
to do with it. [laughter]
Sunny Tate might call you out. Oh, no.
Whatever. I'm not the one promoting
gambling when I have millions of dollars
in all the cars in the world.
>> What did he just put up?
>> All right, let's look at this. Bro, I
didn't want to talk about this. Overall,
I've been a big supporter of Andrew
Tate, but I don't care anymore. I don't
know what is up his watch.
>> What is up his butt? Pause. What's going
on? So, let's look at this tweet. The
West used to be so much more
disconnected. I remember when I moved
from America to England at 10, 28 years
ago, I was amazed that none of the
classmates from my old American school
had the same name as the new classmates
in the English school. The English kids
were called James or Roert, names you
never heard in America. And the
Americans kids were Brad or Jackie,
names you never heard in England. Now
all the kids in every Western school are
just called Muhammad.
You're Muslim, bro. I don't get it.
Like, what is your
>> I don't know. I don't know if that's
true anymore. Look, I'll be honest,
guys, with what he's saying and and I
big up. Obviously, the the foul language
obviously condone that, but he's done
right. We're not going to defend him,
bro. I'm going to expose you, Andrew
hate. I'm going to expose you every
single breath I can. I still believe you
spoke the truth. Like, don't get
twisted. Even Shayan speaks the truth
where they taught it to Abu. Yes,
there's truth. You spoke a lot of truth
of masculinity and there's a lot of
truth. You said there's a lot of
misogyny in your terminology. There's a
lot of red pill. We totally disregard.
There were truths to that and to
masculinity and etc etc etc. Giving a
voice to men as well. Yes. And you came
to Islam and now you're complaining
about people's name being called
Muhammad. Let me tell you something,
bro. You have outright, we can't call
you a kafir. We can't. We can't. Even
though people, we can't call you that
just yet because there is still, you
know, there's some doubt. There's still
something there. Do you get Islam? We
need to be very careful. But believe me,
I can see, bro, you are slowly moving
your way out of Islam. And guess what?
Islam don't need you, bro. You are so
poor. All you have is money, bro. You
are so poor. All you have is money. Let
me tell you something. You're a
multi-millionaire. Okay,
multi-millionaire. What with a couple of
extra 20 million, 30 million, 40
million, 50 million add to you. You know
what it is? You are so poor that only
thing that you have, Andrew Tate, is
money. That's the only thing you have.
That's what you think. Add in those
numbers. Let me tell you something. I
can see you are spiritually dead. I can
see the spiritual starvation in your
eyes. And I know you're going to watch
this video. Yeah. Okay. It's not too
late. You are feeding your soul, your
body, all this kind. We're going to go
to sneakers as well. Sneakers got a
video as well. We're going to talk about
Yeah. I big up sonifas. Yes, these guys.
You can see when it says you could have
been up there with the prophets. He
believes in that. I can see in Sonifaz's
body language when he speaks when it
says with the prophets of God, he
believes that. I believe I me wrong. If
Andrew heard him be laughing, oh yeah,
with a prophet with a god. I genuinely
he will say that. He doesn't believe. He
genuinely doesn't believe that much.
That's what Allah says in the Quran when
Allah said to the bedins, do not say you
believe. Rather say you've just
admitted. Yes, you've said I'm a Muslim.
I iman hasn't entered your heart, bro.
And you say imitate yourself. It's so
far away from you. That's what I want to
go to now this video. Um I want to go to
uh Sneo. Let's see what had to say. I
hope you guys enjoyed the video guys.
But before that, please download the
Salah Pro app. Brothers and sisters, we
are a charity. All of our services on
the app is for free. Free kibla finder.
No ads. Free salah reminders. Encourages
to pray. Tells you salah times. You can
book a salah instructor, a Quran
instructor. You can order a guided
prayer map for absolutely free if you
want to learn how to pray salah. Videos
on how to pray salah. Salah hubs and
many, many more. own sisters. We are not
an app that shares your information with
third parties. All of our services on
the app is for free. Download it now,
inshallah. And enjoy, guys. Let's go
back to the video.
>> Tate promoting gambling. Yeah, let's
let's have a real conversation about
that. I tweeted at Tate yesterday
because after years of saying he didn't
want to stream on kick because they
promote gambling. After years of Tristan
saying that gambling and degeneracy and
porn is ruining the West, Tape promotes
his gambling website. And this is a day
after he said people with the name
Muhammad are ruining the West. Coming
from a Muslim guy, a Muslim guy who's
saying there's too many Muhammads and
then promoting a gambling link. For a
long time, I'll be real with you, a lot
of Muslims have been apprehensive to
talk about Andrew Tate because they
don't want to push him away because they
know the influence he has and they know
that if the most famous revert leaves
Islam, it's going to be very detrimental
and that he could become an apostate and
side with people who call themselves
enemies of Islam.
>> Good point. St made a good point. Of
course, we don't want him to leave Islam
for a variety of reasons. But let me
tell you something. To hell with you,
man. Let me tell you something, bro. to
hell with you. Bro, we don't look into
something here. We have our trust in
Allah. Allah used to bring millions if
not hundreds of thousands of people to
Islam and you leaving is not going to do
nothing.
You know what? Allah has a plan. So,
Siko's right strategically, etc. Of
course, we don't want him. He's a
brother. Of course, we want him to leave
Islam, etc. as well. Strategically as
well, but we're morally consistent as
well. Listen, man, to hell with you,
man, man. Islam doesn't need you. I'm
not trying to push you away. I'm saying
Islam doesn't need you, bro. You need
Islam. You are spiritually dead. So,
sneak away what you're saying is true
there. But let's carry on. If we're
being real, if we want to have a real
conversation, it looks like Tate regrets
becoming Muslim. It seems like he sees
that it's boxed himself in that he wants
to appeal to the that Judeo-Christian
supremacy crowd and so he's he's
distancing himself strategically by
saying little things like there's too
many Muhammads in the West. And so him
after all years of saying that gambling
is evil taking a gambling deal. It's
just like really bro really. So many
people are afraid to call it out too
because they don't want to get attacked.
They saw what happened last year when I
was had a disagreement with Andrew Tate.
Andrew Tate threatened to destroy my
career. You remember that? He said I'm
going to destroy your career but oh he's
a young guy. He's a young guy. I could
destroy his career but I won't. And so
other people don't want the same thing
to happen to them. They want to they see
the the wrongdoing and they ignore it.
Tate response is going to hit. I mean
like look look people are saying oh
you're dissing him this stuff like am I
supposed am I gonna I don't see it. I
don't see the gambling link. I do it
pops up on my timeline or it's on my
timeline too. He says there's too many
Muhammads in the west. Am I supposed to
just be like this is not this is not
like this is what Tom Tommy Rubenstein
would say. That's a straight up Tommy
Rubenstein tweet. You know that guy,
that guy paid for by Israel who's there
in Israel right now kissing the hands of
rabbis, pretending to be Britain first,
pretending to care about England, being
an England and a British nationalist.
Yeah, he's owned by Msad. That's what
Tate is tweeting exactly like him. And
this Tommy Rubenstein is one of the
biggest people advocating for the end of
the spread of Islam and trying to
destroy our reputation completely. And I
so many times when I I try to see the
best in it. I try to look at the other
way and say positive things because
obviously blah blah blah you know the
tape brothers have had a positive impact
and I know them personally but at this
point it's like disappointing.
>> Exactly. There you go. Like Omar Katab
said yes before we used to judge people
based on why revelation coming down.
Revelation has stopped. Now we judge
people from what is apparent. And that
is exactly what we're doing. And we will
do it with both men and women who are
calling to evil. I don't give a damn
what you are. With all your respect, I
don't care if you're hijabi, nabi, a
brother with a long beard, that's up to
his feet. I don't care. Okay, you're
wearing a th whatever. If you call to
evil, bro, we will call you out. And I'm
consistent in this. Subhan Allah. So,
you can see that even Sneo. Yes. May
Allah bless and preserve him. You can
see the guy has iman. You can see that.
But subhan Allah. Yes. And he talks
about the matrix. My friend, you are the
matrix, bro. You are in the matrix. What
are you talking about, man? You're
talking about gambling and this that
destroys lives. Oh, the name Muhammad
such a big danger to UK, Europe. Wow.
What about gambling? What about
gambling, man? That destroys lives and
you're here promoting that. Should we
look at some statistics for gambling?
Let's talk about that. Yes, let's talk
about some statistics with gambling.
Okay. Problem gambling statistics. The
National Council on Problem Gambling,
NCPG, and other sources not the
following statistics. 15% of Americans
gamble at least once a week.
Approximately 2 to 3% of Americans meet
the criteria for problem gambling.
That's around 6 million adults and about
half a million teens. Problem gambling.
What do you mean by problem gambling?
Gambling is gambling. That's you know
it's getting really dangerous. You know
you know you know you might be on the
verge of you know um it's like saying
like as if um thinking about suicide and
this problems are not bad. If but if you
come to the verge of comm now it's the
numbers say this these people they
should not even be thinking about
suicide. Yes I'm just talking in general
giving example. Yeah they shouldn't even
be doing gambling from the get- go.
Okay. Youth risk developing a gambling
problem at a rare at a rate of about two
to three times that of adults and
approximately 6% of college students in
America have a gambling problem. About
60% sorry about 40% of people with a
gambling problem started gambling before
the age of 17. Nevada has the highest uh
prevalence of problem gambling in the
country at about 6.4%. Effects of
problem of gambling. There are there is
an array of harmful effects arising from
problem gambling includes NCBG notes
that the annual cost of association with
gambling crime, addiction and bankruptcy
is $17 billion. Approximately 67% of
problem gamblers are likely to have a
major depressive disorder according to
NCPG. The NCBG also says children
children of pro um problem gamblers are
at a higher risk for a number of
behaviors including problem gambling,
tobacco use and drug use. The Asian
journal of gambling issues issues and
public health states that about 10 to
70% of children of problem gamblers and
about 25 to 50% of spouse of of problem
gamblers have been abused
abused. Subhan Allah. George State
University estimates that about 50% of
problem gamblers commit crimes and about
two twothirds of those crimes were
directly related to the gambling. GC GSU
also notes that 73% of people who are
incarcerated are identified as problem
gamblers. An Australian study found that
one in five suicidal patients had a
gambling problem. Okay, this is America.
Okay, let's go to the UK. Problems of
gambling in the UK. According to Yuggov
prevalent study in 2020, as many as 2.7%
of people in Great Britain of or 1.4
million people might be considered
problem gamblers. However, the
government's gambling commission report
suggests that only 0.2% of these
individuals individuals were like that
helps anything. According to the latest
public health England report uh on
gambling, 0.5% of the population
approximately 246,000 people are problem
gamblers and that's 3.8% 2.2 million
people at the risk of gambling. Do you
know what that means for Do you know
what that means for the effect? Do you
know what that means? the harm that's
going to cause the ripple effect of how
many people are in these people's lives.
Yes. Subhan Allah. So according to
professor Belen Jones, 70 to 70% of
people do well in treatment which means
that they they are not gambling. Who
cares? Who cares man? Why are they even
in that situation? And you're telling me
Islam is a problem when Islam has come
to abolish gambling and alcohol and sex
outside of marriage and all of these
evils because it causes the society's
destruction. And we Muslims are the
problem. You know who's the problem?
Those Zionists who own those pornography
sites, gambling companies, yes, alcohol,
you name it. They are trying to destroy
your youth in the UK. While we Muslims
are here saying, "Let's leave live like
human beings." These are things that are
destroying the mind, the body, and the
soul. And you've got hypocrites like
Andutate. An absolute hypocrite. Subhan
Allah. Who is coming here and now he's
got his own gambling, the best gambling
world. Shame on you. Shame on you for
ruining. Let me tell you something,
Andrew Tate. Do you believe you're going
to find happiness knowing that you are
the cause of destruction of thousands of
families who are gambling, who are on
the verge of suicide? Yes. Do you think
you're ever going to find happiness when
the curse of those people are on you? On
you. Shame on you as a Muslim. You are
promoting gambling and you've got your
own gambling website. Shame on you.
Thank God for Sneo and Sonifas and the
rest of these brothers who are calling
you out and we are going to call you out
because you are fake. That's what you
don't give a crap about anyone but
yourself. So in a nutshell, that's what
I'm going to say. Subhan Allah. May
Allah subhana wa ta'ala expose Andrew
for what he really is. And you can see
day by day his true colors. He's more
concerned about Muhammad names in in the
UK rather than the gambling problem that
he's causing around the world that's
destroying people's lives. Shame on you
and I'm going to carry on exposing you.
Yes, I'm going to carry on exposing you.
Till next time, brother and sisters.
Asalamaikum.
Islam has come to preserve life, the
mind, the body and the soul. Come to
Islam the truth in embrace it truly like
Sneo as 25. Till next time
Andrew never forget you are so poor the
only thing you have is money.